[Música]
la semana pasada se rompió en tres
ocasiones el récord no oficial de calor
a nivel global los datos exponen además
que América Latina y el Caribe ha
alcanzado su mayor tasa de calentamiento
en 30 años las temperaturas en la región
aumentaron en promedio 0,2 grados
Celsius cada década Este es el índice
más alto desde que se tiene registro
para analizar la situación de la región
vamos a conectar con Álvaro sopati él es
especialista en políticas climáticas
globales Álvaro Gracias por estar en
directo a América
muy buenos días Ángela un gusto estar
con ustedes
partes de México de Centroamérica y del
Caribe registraron calor extremo en
junio pasado esto es un fenómeno cíclico
o podemos ver aquí el impacto del
calentamiento global
Gracias muy buena pregunta en general
para observar el impacto del cambio
climático el calentamiento global
tenemos que observar series temporales
más extendidas pero efectivamente el
aumento en la frecuencia de la
intensidad y la duración de estos
eventos nos marcan un patrón que muy
probablemente está asociado al cambio
climático y al calentamiento global
al mismo tiempo sucede en Casos como el
de Uruguay que está enfrentando una
fuertísima sequía que tiene a sus
autoridades en jaque Y además que
representa un gran riesgo Pues porque no
hay agua hay una sequía que que no
permite que haya agua potable suficiente
para la población
Sí sí efectivamente esto este patrón
también está relacionado muy
probablemente con el calentamiento
global o con el cambio climático el
déficit
hídrico o la reducción de las
precipitaciones en toda la zona del del
sudeste de Sudamérica que no solo afecta
a Uruguay Aunque en este caso particular
o Los afectados especialmente sino
también a al noreste de Argentina y al
sureste de Brasil es un evento que ya
lleva Algunos años que se está
acentuando y bueno ahora vamos a ver qué
sucede durante estos próximos meses a
ver si cambia el patrón Pero además a
estas condiciones que se dan en la
región se suma el anuncio de la
Organización meteorológica Mundial hay
que declaró la llegada oficial de El
niño Quiero preguntarle por las
implicaciones que tiene este fenómeno si
tenemos en cuenta pues el ambiente
climático actual Sí muchas gracias
Ángela nuevamente es una pregunta
interesante Porque
se están siempre realizando muchos
estudios sobre el fenómeno del niño la
niña y su interacción con el cambio
climático en términos generales podemos
decir que muy probablemente tal como lo
dijo la omm la Organización
meteorológica Mundial estamos iniciando
un periodo de niños con alta
probabilidad no es que 100% seguro pero
es muy probable esto puede tener
implicancias diferentes en distintas
regiones por ejemplo dentro de lo que es
latinoamérica en el sureste o el sur de
Sudamérica podrían aumentar
significativamente las precipitaciones
mientras que en el norte de Sudamérica o
en Centroamérica del Caribe podría haber
un déficit también
hídrico una reducción de las
precipitaciones afecta a distintas
maneras a cada a cada su región bueno Y
aquí tenemos que preguntarnos si están
los países de la región preparados para
asumir esta falta de agua o esta falta
de recursos hídricos que se va a
presentar
Bien también es una pregunta muy muy
interesante depende de cada país y no
solo de cada país sino de cada de cada
su región dentro de los países ahí hay
países que vienen trabajando hace hace
tiempo en políticas no solo de
adaptación al cambio climático o en
general sino de infraestructura hídrica
otros países están un poco más rezagados
pero también depende de las condiciones
estructurales de los sistemas
productivos el tipo de del nivel de
desarrollo de cada país y de las de las
sociedades que lo que lo habitan no es
solamente a nivel a nivel país pero en
general han habido avances en las
últimas pero todo en la última década
por lo menos en algunos aspectos como
sistemas de alerta temprana o sobre todo
lo que hace información Eso ha crecido
mucho Álvaro en otros temas una de las
consecuencias más complejas del
calentamiento global es el aumento en el
nivel de los océanos de este tema se ha
hablado mucho pero concentrándonos en
esta problemática Cuáles son los países
de nuestra región que más se han visto
afectados hasta el momento
bien de acuerdo al mismo informe que has
mencionado de la omm por lo menos en
América Latina y el Caribe Se observa
que en algunas zonas como en el Océano
Atlántico sur o en el Atlántico Norte
subtropical el aumento a nivel del mar
ha sido un poco superior a la media
global lo cual tiene implicancias serias
sobre todo bueno en los países costeros
de estas dos regiones que acabo de
mencionar y los posibles impactos o
impactos que inclusive ya están
observando tienen que ver No solo con la
intrusión Salina del océano sobre sobre
las napas de Agua Dulce sino también el
aumento de probabilidad de de eventos
relacionados con con las crecidas de los
mares en las zonas costeras y daños en
la infraestructura esos son algunos de
los de los de los problemas Más allá de
los que ya estamos escuchando hace
tiempo y los que se pueden acrecentar
como los eventos extremos del estilo
Huracanes como están mostrando que
también se han intensificado sobre todo
en Centroamérica y el Caribe Y en este
caso Cuáles son las medidas puntuales
que deberían aplicar los gobiernos ante
el escenario de poblaciones inundadas o
de dificultad para el acceso a los
recursos hídricos
bien muchas gracias son muchas las
medidas también nuevamente depende del
contexto y depende de las posibilidades
en términos generales para reducir el
riesgo de este tipo de eventos y
trabajar sobre sobre la vulnerabilidad
de estas de estos sistemas estas
poblaciones algunas de las medidas
tienen que ver con lo que es la misma
infraestructura es decir aumento o
inversiones En sistemas de contención o
de protección ante las crecidas de del
nivel del mar o en el caso que sean Ríos
es lo mismo por otro lado como mencioné
antes los sistemas de alerta temprana de
los cuales se habla mucho y no siempre
las políticas acompañan son
fundamentales porque esto permite que
las poblaciones puedan prepararse con
mayor anticipación ahí hay países que
tienen mucha experiencia en esto estas
son algunas de las tantas tantas medidas
y luego la planificación o la ordenación
el ordenamiento territorial tiene
también que ver lo que es una medida de
mucho más largo plazo más compleja
política y económicamente pero que al
final hace la diferencia para evitar que
haya poblaciones sobreexpuestas en zonas
que mucha probabilidad de peligro de
ocurrencia estos fenómenos Bueno al
final de los países del sur global somos
los que más duramente sufrimos los
efectos del cambio climático
provocados también en gran parte por los
mayores contaminantes del mundo que no
están en el sur global qué tan
importante es para usted de que exista
una política conjunta
que pida responsabilidad y finalmente
Pues el planeta es el mismo el cielo nos
cubre a todos pues para que se puedan
revertir O al menos ralentizar estos
efectos
muy muy buena también esta pregunta es
compleja la respuesta Lo que sabemos es
que necesitamos una acción coordinada y
global como bien has dicho en segundo
lugar el aumento o la sostenibilidad de
las flujos el flujo financieros sobre
todos de los países del Norte global
hacia los países en desarrollo o los
países menos adelantados es fundamental
para para proseguir sobre todo con los
esfuerzos de adaptación al cambio
climático y por otra parte en todo lo
que hace la mitigación que es lo que en
cambio climático se refiere a la
reducción de las emisiones de gases o el
aumento de las absorciones es todavía
más desafiante porque efectivamente los
países más vulnerables o los que más
padecen los efectos del cambio climático
en su mayoría no son los que más han
contribuido al al problema esto exige
una concertación que se está dando muy
gradualmente en la arena internacional
pero todavía resta mucho mucho camino
por recorrer y bueno año esperamos que
esto esto vaya vaya cambiando Y por
último si quería agregar la dificultad o
la complejidad de lo que hace al cambio
de las matrices energéticas por ejemplo
que es fundamental para la reducción de
las emisiones pero que lleva enormes e
inversiones y en sentido también se
necesita el apoyo financiero de los
países desarrollados una discusión que
seguro tendremos para otro día gracias a
ustedes Álvaro sopati especialista en
políticas climáticas globales Gracias
vamos a hacer una pequeña pausa ya
volvemos con más en directo América
quédese con nosotros
[Música]